back on U.S soil this a prime minister
at home on both sides of the Atlantic in
Washington DC for his fourth meeting
with President Biden in as many months
old allies in times of peace and War the
Prime Minister honoring U.S servicemen
at Arlington National Cemetery two
Nations bow not just by past conflicts
but current ones too prime minister you
say you don't know yet who is
responsible for the dam attack in
Ukraine but if it turns out that Russia
is responsible what actions will you
take it's too early for us to say
definitively the cause of the attack our
military and security services are
currently investigating it but if it is
intentional it would represent an
unprecedented level of barbarism
in lockstep on Ukraine the Prime
Minister wants to use this trip to get
his foot in the door on artificial
intelligence and play a leadership role
in mitigating its risks it's confusing
can you paint a picture of the risk well
look I'm not I'm not going to get into
this business of of scaremongering
people because I think what people will
say well hang on there's a new
technology which we don't fully know yet
what it's capable of doing the pace of
that technology is accelerating at a
rate that people didn't quite think was
possible so what you're saying is if
it's not regulated properly it could be
on the scale of equivalent to nuclear
risk it could kill humans we have to
monitor it I have to regulate it it's
absolutely right that we put guard rails
in place because the technology is
enormously powerful it's going to
reshape every aspect of our lives and
whilst that will bring many
opportunities and benefits it also poses
risks not just existential but also
risks of misuse of the technology
the PM looking for a win on AI here but
back home at risk of missing his own
Target to halve inflation by December
with all the Fallout that brings two of
your five pledges a con inflation half
by the end of the year the UK out of
recession by the end of the year if you
fail on either of them do you take
personal responsibility you don't blame
the bank of England you don't blame
consumers you don't blame businesses
it's on you parsley because they're your
personal Prejudice of course it's on me
personally I'm the Prime Minister I'm
the person who set out those five
pledges to halve inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
to stop the boats and I intend to
deliver on those so it's a deal break
with the British public if you don't
deliver it by the end of the year that's
on you it's an absolutely my
responsibility I've told the public to
hold me accountable they should be able
to have politicians who deliver what
they say and that's what I intend to do
pm to meetings on Capitol Hill how do we
make sure
here to discuss the special relationship
with key leaders across the political
divide tomorrow to the Oval Office for a
one-on-one with President Biden where
he'll hope to turn warm words into
concrete winds bath Rigby Sky News in
Washington